[Music]
each team will have to assemble of 13
pieces in front of you to create the
perfect Cube
and it's classic over 19 000 unique
Solutions each with multiple approaches
so it's really going to test your
spatial understanding and critical
thinking skills
this final challenge would push your
special reasoning to its limits you'll
need to consider all the geometric
permutations of rotation and translation
to optimize your solution
let me introduce you to one of my
favorite kinds of shapes and I'd love
you to draw this with me
this
is a pentomino you've heard of dominoes
before right Domino's two squares joined
together a pentomino has five squares
joined together you can count in there
one two three four five okay now it
doesn't take too much imagination to
realize this is not the only way to
combine five squares together into a
single shape to make another pentometer
there are many different types right for
example I could just take all five of
these squares and I could put them like
what's the simplest kind of shape you
could make across just okay fantastic
let's do a cross together right so if
you do one of those bam five squares
okay let me give you two minutes to see
how many more you can come up with we've
got two as a group I'm pretty confident
you can come up with the complete lists
two minutes go oh God we get to know how
many there are um no that's part of the
that's part of the challenge
and I'm gonna stop you when I think
you're close enough and we can get them
all together we cannot get them all
five squares try to be a little bit
systematic but to be honest you can
actually get them in random order I can
tell you now as a whole group you almost
have all of them but but no one
individually is close but as a group
you're doing pretty well just lovely now
I will say as well
um you can flip them over but they'd be
the same shape right like if you spin
one around and you're like oh it's just
that little uh that little Edge on this
one has just gone to a different spot
it's still the same shape yeah so don't
worry too much about reflecting and
rotating because then it's still the
same thing and you'll have a lot of them
okay I'm gonna hit pause on you there I
reckon we can get these together all
right so we've got this one we've got
this one someone described to me a shape
that you got long stick the long stick
very technical term okay so we can just
line up all five one two three four okay
give me another one a full stick with
one on the end a four stick with one on
the end so four and then one down and
then one down okay so kind of an L shape
all right good so we've got some of that
all right uh where else can we go a t a
t Okay so I guess if we put three there
and then how's that okay T with long top
t with a long one lowercase t uh over to
here sort of thing yeah okay all right
yeah it is like that that's a t like
that yeah okay let me pause there right
now just because of time I'm just going
to pause in terms of the drawing right
what do we got here one two three four
five six there are you'll notice there
are more on your page so we have not
drawn already
there are 12 in total there are 12
pentometers and I already saw every
single one of them on someone's piece of
paper okay now not a rhetorical question
each pentomino five squares
12 of them times five how many squares
in total six sixty sixty Now 60 is a
really important number in maths right
it's important because there's lots of
ways to factorize it and that's why we
base our time system on 60 60 minutes an
hour 60 seconds in a minute because it's
easy to divide up right you could do
this as let's do it on my fingers uh one
times sixty
two times thirty help me out three times
twenty four times five times twelve and
then lastly six times ten right now you
can see that if you took all of these
squares just jumbled them all up you
could actually make a nice neat
rectangle
this is actually not the right number
but you get the right idea okay that
would have 60 squares in it right
do you think it's possible to take the
12 pentometers that you've all drawn and
arrange them nicely into a rectangle
with no like holes in the middle no bits
sticking out yes yes yeah yes it's
possible in fact it's possible in
hundreds and thousands of different ways
this is in two dimensions
what you're going to be doing is in
three of course because of course this
is the ultimate classroom after all so
let me say one more time this final
challenge will push your spatial
reasoning to its limits you'll need to
consider all the geometric permutations
of rotation and translation to optimize
your solution
good luck teams I'm really eager to see
how you go looks like blue team you can
see it's like oh there's almost a
there's almost a cube there yeah right
we started succeeding it looks like
we're like cute yeah gonna get a q
version one piece just sticks out and we
have to like start again yeah
foreign